we've been married almost six years yeah
but we've been together since we were
like 13 and so he decided to make me a
journal Oh God I'm what an Aquarius is
on every single page not step in the
worst gifts I ever given is like I was
like almost everything I ever gotten
that she's not that hard to please just
has to be meaning be creative and don't
be boring it's like the worst advice
that ever I think I got this online
we'll really similar we like the same
things it's some really tough because
all I'm not a boy what are the big
mittens for just big oh sorry I don't
know I'm doing
yeah we're not ready for that yeah I
don't know what that means oh I don't
know if I'm in the right place this
place is so cool
no luck yet she likes books Oh made me
feel like a book you know great
presentation she gets a point for their
socks that's what I'm talking about at
these to my repertoire who would want
socks oh it's a break please oh these
are so I think they were both really
good gifts but maybe Kristin maybe you
did a little bit better this time
fancy hmm Santa's boat help oh my god
it's like a zebra slow-cooker you like
it yeah yeah yeah I love it how do you
react to a slow cover like it's just oh
my gosh this is awesome
I've read about this artist but it's our
favorite donut shop
I think the pillow is a better gift okay
it's more like us